GORAN K. HANSSON: The Royal
Swedish Academy of Sciences
has today decided to award
the Sveriges Riksbank
Prize in Economic Sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel
to Angus Deaton for his analysis
of consumption, poverty,
and welfare.
ANGUS DEATON: 6:10 this
morning-- and I remember
the time pretty precisely-- the
phone rang and Ann picked it up
before I could
get through to it.
We were both awake.
And she handed it
to me and there
was this very nice
Swedish lady saying,
is this Professor Angus Deaton?
I have an important call
for him from Stockholm.
So I had a pretty good
idea of what it was then.
This really seemed
like for real.
And I still feel
a little bit bit
that we might pinch
ourselves and wake up.
And I'll be back in bed and
it'll be an ordinary day.
I am pretty pleased, yes.
[CLAPPING]
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: I
myself first met Angus shortly
after I joined the Woodrow
Wilson School faculty
and was immediately
impressed with his leadership
in the school and
his willingness
to tackle important questions.
I am thrilled that this
year's Nobel Prize was awarded
to someone who is
both a great economist
and a great Princetonian.
CECILIA ROUSE: He's a
giant in this field,
but not one to wear
that on his sleeve.
He's a true gentleman.
He's kind to colleagues,
students, and staff
equally, and respected by all.
He's also a wonderful
friend and, Angus,
I couldn't be more proud.
Congratulations.
You do the school so very proud.
Thank you.
[CLAPPING]
SHOUMITRO CHATTERJEE: This
is the news that all of us
had been waiting
for for a long time.
We are all very, very excited.
His contributions in
academia are tremendous.
We learned a lot
from his scholarship
so this is fantastic news.
JANET CURRIE: Angus has
had enormous influence
with or without the Nobel Prize.
And so, I want to raise
a toast to influencing
the world through your work
and through your students--
something we all aspire to.
[CLAPPING]
SUBJECT 1: I just want
to say how honored we are
to be part of this celebration.
ANGUS DEATON: Oh, thank you.
SUBJECT 1: Congratulations.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SUBJECT 1: Would
it be OK if we take
one quick picture with you?
ANGUS DEATON: Sure.
SUBJECT 2: Thank you.
We're your new fan club.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SUBJECT 2: Come on in.
Come on in.
More students.
SUBJECT 3: Thank you so much.